what's happened to reject nation Greg
Albie and John Humphrey over here
giant tennis ball gladiator from rack of
Rekha
catching up on Iraq Iraq of this a week
that poori onto this want to give a
heads up to James taken to the picture
of the day and this shout out to look
out for that buddy yeah I love what
they're doing with their money
[Music]
alright stop fans just come from the
airport we met him in Japan right no but
it feels very much like a couple weeks
not LA on just about example with of
maniacs one why do you scare it all my
more exact che check out a fool up and
then you [ __ ] come out of it already
excited on that Donna keeps all each
money my friend Sam finally a minute
Emily nice I don't think I heard you
guys say longer right we'll give you a
tour of the house kitchen where you put
food and eat you will send a long time
in your sense this is sunny has a sauna
this one on the stairs
oh they ruin the bail hearing damn
these guys will literally have me out
like really failing how are you gonna
get over that
yeah so we're your friends
I said he only gave me off all in the
middle wipe every side and run into the
ball last one standing wins sand bushes
fun aside oh by the way we've been
hitting the gym on salt this is Leon day
one this is real date 30 this is real
they pick you can you see a difference
if you can I'm more cut on day 30
[Music]
[Music]
kind of like level over you get it first
- and God never leaves it when there's a
plan who's gonna win this
[Music]
we played errorless [ __ ] meet Jamie my
secret weapon [ __ ] quality
[Music]
whoa your exercise looks a lot bigger
than me
hahaha there's a lot of like or
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
haha
[Music]
all right everyone this is gonna be me
crazy we're gonna play this in the world
we're not a bad concrete ah ain't go on
every time they do de hey I wish I can
do you guys the bad you should cannot
peacefully and look I know it takes her
seriously when she's mad well the
records the new jackass yeah yeah but
they've become look if you took a blog
and and made it jackass yeah which I got
ass at like walk I'm gonna big blogs guy
but the stuff his name video because I
went back and I watched the the first
you know we got a mansion video and then
when we did before and I'm enjoying
their version you have long their
hyperkinetic crazy painful personal it
is exactly what it rack Iraq I made a
vlog yeah we had a question I'm happy
that I got to see yeah
whereas other questions in our last
reaction yeah I'm really curious what it
was you liked to hang out with these
guys that ball game was like a lot of
fun actually like in the park I feel
like that'd be a total blast to do I
give it a try I'm gonna try was really
fun I would have do it on the street no
no not hate men like that no that's what
I admire about those dudes they're not
afraid to get scuffed up they're not
afraid to get hurt anything for
entertainment those guys not a shelf a
DVDs over on you whatever they want I
mean I'm at the twins at VidCon and
they're pretty energetic hyper dudes
really yeah so I would actually like to
see this and all their friends are very
much on a similar wavelength is pretty
crazy to me man yeah these guys are the
new jackass
yeah yeah well in the end I never even
got to like the way their mom is they're
like all right she's like Sam's mom yeah
yeah exactly the way Mr Jeremiah that
we're like glimpse into family light and
I would get back to making each other
hurt yeah I'm enjoying their blows I
can't wait to do another sketch again
yeah hey that scared the house record
stuff it was a lot of fun and then you
know I got a matter they're busy making
a movie I think so you know this seems
like a nice way to keep up the channel
if they can't do a sketch as frequent
and their videos are definitely in
restricted mode I can't imagine that
Google Adsense money saying much right
now I did I think they're probably
uploading a lot more to make it overall
into it just got a mansion they gotta
pay the bills way maybe not yet maybe
now a vlog would be lucrative yeah yeah
instead of it once a month got [ __ ] yeah
all right guys go subscribe to raka raka
and worth a to subscriber the real
rejects James Stegen Jimbo Staggs a
longtime follower of this channel I've
been calling him Stevens for way too
long
I can see how you would make that error
and then he interrupted us and the
mellah our Google hangout and he was
like I have to tell you it is not stayin
to Seguin any deal it's actually like
spoken so credibly can we go Alex
it's got to tell you even saying Stig
and nuts bagans and it's just saying
you're wrong yes sir no of course sir
I'll I'll say right now John respond I
was like what's your problem Stevens
I'll probably what about 1 to N word
pronunciation is objective your fault
you know let me say it wrong for so many
years
yeah well kids man but on serious I'm
happy for being a follower of this
channel for so long and thank you for
being a part of our patreon James hey
gay subscribe to the real rejects full
at the Greg Alva on Twitter and
Instagram
my name is dead John Humphrey on Twitter
and Instagram and click that
notification bill get notes case is
notified every time a review or a video
is out and you got cool rewards and
perks on patreon we've got a t-shirt
source stores we got a t-shirt store
nail shop Spreadshirt calm all kinds of
things stay gives you dog